[Music]
all right guys
this here is candice she's a student
from dallas
and she just one morning she was having
a really bad day
so she decided to just clear some stuff
up she went on her linkedin
she noticed she had a voice message
which she was like what the heck i don't
even know
link linkedin had voice messages oh i
gotta check mine
you got a linkedin forgot about linkedin
i don't even like that
you know what's really odd is someone
asked me
on email if i had a linkedin to do
business
what a loser and i was like but you're
emailing me
i don't have a link you're so
unprofessional get on instagram duh
you're like bro i don't even have a
shirt on
i know it's like you're trying to prove
like what like you want to do business
with me
this is what you get i don't even know
come on
you spell shirt wrong too hurt i'm sure
i don't even have a shirt on dude sure
they like how joe says it all right so
back to candice so
she checked her linkedin and she knows
she had a voice message from
jimmy 77 year old sweet jimmy from
california why are you so close to the
camera
it's just the photo the canvas is normal
at selfies and then
well this doesn't look like a selfie it
looks like it's a really zoomed in photo
of
a different he looks like he does taxes
very appropriately like and he will
never cut a corner
no one's seen this on social media no
well
this is his voice message you ready yeah
hello candice how are you doing
and good morning how have you been
[Music]
hey candace this is me jimmy
from linkedin and the reason i was
giving you this quick
voice message call was to say thank you
so kindly
i really appreciate that you have
accepted me here
on the linkedin flat platform
what we will do is learn from each other
i appreciate your kindness jimmy
from linkedin how cute
he's so old people with technology is
the best
jimmy from linkedin it sounds like the
voice that bart puts on when he's doing
his swab voice
jimmy i feel like old people are really
[ __ ] good
at voice messaging like like levering
thing on the answering machine or
whatever because they're used to
like keeping it brief precise and just
leaving [ __ ] like all the information
i don't know bro can i have a baby
it's a boy my mom when my mom calls or
does something like that i hear like
hello steven steven yeah it's like she's
struggling with it like the phone's
trying to strangle her
i wouldn't even know what to summarize
if they're like please leave a message
after the top
ah [ __ ] i forgot what i was even gonna
say yeah cause my mom does the same [ __ ]
too she'll call me it goes into
voicemail she goes geo
hey geo oh like if you had an answering
machine how cute
okay well it's mom i'm like i know it's
you
yeah then she tells me your message
that's so cute because i remember back
in the day
when you would leave voicemails you
would be talking to the machine for a
little while because you were hoping
that
the person is hearing this message and
run to the to the actual
phone and pick up the the call i
remember those don't think my phone ever
did that your your house phone lan phone
it doesn't uh well at least we didn't
have one that would play on speaker
it would just kind of record in and then
you can click play later because it
seems like
it would be kind of weird it could be
like a problem of privacy
sometimes oh yeah like yeah back in the
day households like that it wasn't
private it was just like
hey we're calling from kaiser and it's
just messages or whatever or
they just put it like hey your daughter
didn't show up to school today and
you're like
you had company over at the time they'd
be like what the [ __ ] happening
yeah it's loud the whole house can hear
yeah yeah is that what screaming calls
meant
like you you wait for the person to find
like so you can find out who it was and
then you pick it up because i remember
like tlc had that in one of those there
was caller
i remember we had to buy the separate
caller id blocks yeah yeah i remember
that
that was full that's your hole add that
[ __ ]
if you were used to it and then somebody
calls and it's unknown you're like what
the [ __ ]
do i even pick this up okay then they
block it is it star 69 to block star 69
is to call them back
val's revolution 82 is to block i think
i was star 67
seven yeah star 69 is how i caught every
crank call that i ever got as a kid
yeah because you call back to their
house and then it's like hey this is
like ah you're you're the son of a
bitch's dad i remember you felt like
such like a like a pro
internet hacker when people were like
how'd you call me back i was like i
start 69 they're like oh [ __ ] how'd you
do
that you're like i just told you star 60
now
it's in the name we knew how to get free
phone calls
at pay phones with the paper clip dude
wow oh is it the same way you
you hacked the uh the meters kind of
but um you have a ground it's like a
ground like under the
the phone wire and then the other one
within
the speaking piece there's like a hole
and you put the first paper clip inside
like you undo it and then you have that
in the hole
and you hang it up and then you push it
and then you open it and somehow i think
that
like paper clip thingy it's like
signaling that there's quarters going in
or some [ __ ] do you remember uh taking
advantage of the collect calls
you guys remember collect calls are so
you call you call right and then the
other person goes
they pick up and they go hey uh this
person is calling you do you want to pay
for it almost as if it's a call from
jail
do you accept the charges the name the
window to say your name but now the
window
just just go uh they go what is your
name you'll pick me up at nine so now
my mom picks it up hey would you like to
pay for the phone
pick me up at nine then my mom goes no
and then push your nose when i remember
there was the
the page i forgot which they did a bad
job with branding because i don't
remember which company it was but there
was a company that had advertisements
like that where they were at the
hospital
and this whole family was like like bob
had a baby it's a boy
i remember that remember that i do
remember that bob he had a baby it's a
boy i remember that yeah
that does sound familiar was that a
collect commercial collect call
commercials
it was like a geico commercial or
something i don't remember but they were
just saying like
pretty much like highlighting that
little thing how they're just taking
advantage
of the collect calls for sure but anyway
back to jimmy here from
linkedin is he a creeper or he's just
happy she's happy to make her friends
he thinks she's attractive kind of thing
so that's the thing a lot of people were
like
what the [ __ ] this dude's a creep he's
that old he's going to linkedin to pick
up on a 22 year old
oh and then like what the hell like
obviously he's using linkedin to meet
women or whatever
shut the [ __ ] up really i was the most
innocent [ __ ] i've ever heard
i thought that was businessy yeah i
thought he was like collecting business
cards i think that's what he's doing
first it felt creepy because the way he
said it he continued it and he
didn't say anything that was actually
creepy in words yeah i was like oh
that's just the way he talks how nice
he's just a playful guy yeah exactly so
then candace the woman who received this
message and was the one who tweeted it
out she tweeted out with the caption was
this really necessary jimmy from
linkedin with like
five question marks yes so for her she
was just saying like
you know that day i just had a really
bad day but hearing that message
just really like lightened up the mood
it cracked me up i thought it was so
funny i couldn't i just kept thinking
like there's no way this is real
um we all need a jimmy from linkedin to
hit us up i like it yeah so then when
she tweeted it out eventually it got
to his granddaughter and so that's when
candace spoke to the granddaughter
because
candace actually forgot to respond to
jimmy she had such a busy day so i don't
think they ever
ended up talking again but she ended up
talking to the granddaughter and the
granddaughter was saying like
no like he's just a really sweet
enthusiastic kind of guy like he wasn't
trying to pick on you and even
um pick pick up on you or pick on you
you up yeah anyway so then so then uh
jimmy ends up saying i like the linkedin
platform because i get to meet
like-minded people like myself i use it
to expose the business that i'm
promoting
which by the way i was trying to find
out what business he had and i couldn't
he didn't even get to promote it through
all this [ __ ] linkedin
so he was saying like he's married he's
in california like he's not trying to
pick up on women or using the site to
pick on women
it's just that he wanted to thank
candice and that he actually sends these
voice messages to anyone who
responds to his friend request like
accepts it and he's just like you know i
just love meeting people and so now that
this has
gone so viral he's just super happy and
he says that he's been meeting more
people through this so that's all he
really wanted how cute i bet his
mind is [ __ ] melted the fact that
like back in his day
they would like write [ __ ] said
pigeons to like communicate
and now it's like all over the world at
his fingertips dude even sending
messages through your phone right now
and then how it deletes itself yeah why
did you delete it
that's so weird not mission impossible
right it deletes itself if you send if i
send you a voicemail
yeah the minute he listens to it the
message is gone and if you want to keep
it you can't even keep it it makes me
sad but then why does this mean you keep
it
where can there is an option to keep it
yeah where do you retrieve it
because i've seen that that pop up
before where it says like so and so kept
voice message or they've actually called
me out on it and it's like oh tiff why'd
you keep my voice message
i'm like i didn't even know i mean uh
you can't keep it though the sender
can't keep it
if i send it to steve he can keep it but
if i want him how do you retrieve it
i can't i don't know yeah how are people
going to keep my booty booty booty
rocking everywhere
when i send that your ringtone no when i
say it to sing it to people
and then they just disappear and that's
by the way not hitting on them it's a
warm greeting
they used to be my call back or the the
ring back
you remember verizon i think they still
have it verizon has this option where
when someone calls
you instead of a that telephone ring
it's a song
and that used to be booty bunny buddy i
want to take you for the booty booty
booty
that was me i can't believe i like over
professionalism because i live in such a
unprofessional world even in our
professional companies so i forget
right you don't say
i forget and i was i was hiring a uh uh
going through a hiring process for a new
assistant and he was very professional
and i was looking at him like why you
being a fake fool
and i was like oh wait a minute cause
i'm his boss like he's supposed to be
he can't be treating me like a friend
that's disrespectful right and then i'm
like okay good he's very professional
he's very
cautious okay cause i was taking the
offense to that [ __ ]
to his professional [ __ ] why are you
standing so straight
and speaking to me so damn
professionally we're gonna tie this
[ __ ]
when you have an assistant what do you
have them do usually suck my dick
[Music]
hold his butt cheeks for him oh yeah
pick [ __ ] lemons
very professional guy holding his butt
too i pay people to hang out with me we
went paddle boarding
that's cool wait really yeah for his job
interview i took him paddle boarding
how fun yeah and then he fell and i was
like you didn't get the job
there's another funny uh job interview
guy
and he ended up trying to propose a
business plan to me oh geez
and i got to show you guys this video
this was like years ago though
but it was like a kid probably about 18
or 19.
he had this church business suit on that
was a little too oversized oh
cute he had a little uh chalkboard and
he goes
he was like joe
i would like to propose a business plan
to you
in my business idea i have this is my
business plan
and in my business plan um we're gonna
make a lot of money
the business um as you can see is a very
profitable business plan
and what's using these words and he kept
saying business plan
was the business i don't even remember
but he just kept saying business plan
and he kept saying i have a big big
opportunity big big opportunity and i
was like this dude is trying to [ __ ]
team up with me and oh my god it was so
funny that's like a great
house but business style it's like a guy
has something really [ __ ] on shark tank
and he's just like i know this is a scam
i'm just gonna say a bunch of buzz words
and hopefully one of you goes for it
i don't even think he knew what he was
saying like i just think he
found business words and he started
saying that oh geez
because i was like what is he saying i
don't know i gotta find it that was
hilarious
oh he sent you a video yeah that's i was
watching the video
yeah and then i hired pat instead
[Music]
my